[Music]
what
is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on we found a part of a man
in the woods today
part of the man i guess the other half
was found
in the mine
well this has got to be an animal right
no animal i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belongs to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
it's a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth for you yeah
he is my responsibility
[Music]
he's here
what is going on
it's okay baby it's okay
it's okay it's okay we're okay we're
okay
okay where where where mom
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
run
i don't know why he came all the way up
here there's nothing left
please are people out there worth saving
the people that are left another kind of
people worth saving
[Music]
[Music]
you get the truck come back with the
money that's
2.5 million dollars per head
if you come back alive
[Music]
from tile
[Music]
foreign
foreign
what do you got there oh it's just my
wife emma this is my son charlie
enjoy a lot less well last nothing
happier than the wife of a new detective
that was cool man she's different you
know my wife you give a woman
600 tuesdays it ain't worth three
saturday nights
how much money you got a lot how many
problems you got a lot how many people
doubted your life all available
detective banks in route
whoever did this has another motive
[Music]
the targeting cops
this shit's gonna go sideways fast
someone's out there pulling all the
strings
you want to play games [ __ ]
[Music]
there she is guess what
daddy is going to get you dressed for
school today
we are descendants of the gods
this land was always ours but we must
never relent
or nowhere and everywhere
you're from virginia right i can tell
you're special we are the future
[Music]
you you're not like the others
whoever you were before
that's over
[Music]
what are we doing what
is the plan
[Applause]
tonight 9-1-1
what is your emergency
[Music]
what's the last thing you remember danny
he said we had to run
the reason you survived is because
you're a very
uncommon girl
you're not alone not anymore
do you know what mutants are
would anyone like to share their first
time rain
i was 13. i thought it was a dream
i just lost control sam
i started panicking people got hurt
roberto my girlfriend that burned her
tiliana i killed 18 men one
by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
[Applause]
it's important we find out your power so
we can help you get better
i saw something
i don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't think we're here to get better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes you live through it until it
kills you
he's there
we can get out of this together
[Music]
there is an elevator in the elevator
you press the button to the floor with
no name
behind those doors there's a life
you always tremble
[Music]
the plane it's here this weekend
you will be our guest hear anything
and everything is possible no service
it's not everything is possible good
evening
i'm mr rurik let me officially welcome
you to
fantasy island
[Applause]
i'm curious how this all works what if
your fantasy involves a person from your
life
holograms like tupac what if it's
somebody who died
tupac so what's your fantasy revenge on
a childhood bully
your life is about to change
[Music]
i hope you're ready
that is a really good hologram there is
only one fantasy per guest
[Music]
and you must see your fantasy through he
brought her back
no matter what
oh my god that's really her
work this is not what i meant what the
hell is this place
people die here the island's twisting
what we asked for
we're brought here to have our own
fantasies
we were brought here to be a part of
something else
i'm your friend i've always wanted to
hear you say that
[Music]
i'm anna fox there are some things that
need to be said about me
i have an anxiety disorder
i live across the street my mom asked me
to give you this i'm not prepared for
visitors
i'm a agoraphobic i can't go outside
[Music]
you let some of the outside come in your
neighbor
from across the street pretty sure
you're not supposed to be taking these
with alcohol
her name is jane russell she's become a
friend
like your earrings oh thanks a gift from
an old boyfriend
does your husband mind you could feel my
pain our family's complicated
nypd why is he here mr russell believes
that you made a mistake
you have never met my wife we spent the
evening together
i'm jane russell she's not jane
i know what i saw your doctor said that
your
meds can cause hallucinations
why are you protecting them
they're all hiding something
i heard earring it's in their house
you're playing with the wrong family
do they know you're here alone
9-1-1 i think somebody is in my house
don't go looking into other people's
houses
you won't like what you see
what up kids it's cole this is erl
i've traveled all over the world looking
for the wildest experiences to entertain
you guys
you watched commented and told me what
to do next i challenge all of you to
find something that scares me i dare you
come on
we are taking you to an escape room
experience in moscow
i have a buddy named alexi he wants to
take us everywhere
i'm talking the best clubs the best
restaurants
this guy's so rich that everything he
does is the best
i've been to escape rooms man but not
one like this because they make it just
for you
you have to be invited look i get that
there are two sides of you
there's this public hole and there's
this private cold
i just don't really know the real you
remember
as real as everything might seem you're
safe
sketchy at all it will begin streaming
it directly
into your device from the cameras let's
do it
this is crazy hello
[Music]
what happened here what the hell is this
this is your guy you was just talking
i don't know i'm all that well what we
are in russia with some guy that you
barely know
are you crazy we don't have our phones
our wallets passports anything we need
to leave now
people are paying to watch they change
it every single time it's intense but
it's a game
i couldn't say nothing earlier because
he is always watching
hello cole how do you know my name
is young americans
do you think what if this is still part
of it no we lost look at the timer
please let her go mine is just
a little more selective than yours
oh yo delete that last part no dude this
is live
hello it's peter spencer
i'm here about selling the house does
anyone help
hello
this is detective muldoon this is peter
spencer something happened to me at 44
rayburn drive
[Applause]
someone was murdered at the house why
did he never go into that place
something never felt right about it
[Music]
looks like we got another one
do you think that the body refounds
related
hello i went to the house
hello police department
[Music]
i think something followed me home mommy
what's going on
what's wrong we need to leave right now
[Applause]
[Music]
listen carefully you are now 5 000 miles
from land
and you're descending seven miles to the
bottom of the ocean
see you all in a month here we go
all right we're gonna do this let's do
[Music]
this
i'm gonna scale from one to ten how
bad's my rig
i drilled to the bottom of the ocean and
we don't know what came out
gotta get to the station how will you
even get there
we walk we're just gonna walk with
insufficient oxygen across the bottom of
the ocean
you don't know what's out there worst
idea ever
what was that turn your lights off
there's someone's following us
dude i'm home
dude
[Music]
gotcha it's fun to be scared sometimes
huh
it's bad it's just they don't it's
pretty violent
i understand that some of jude's
behaviors would be upsetting but i urge
you to find a place where he feels safe
i think it will be good for him good for
all of us
oh my goodness look at that that must be
the main house come on dude
[Music]
[Music]
looks like he was broken before and put
back together
who's this handsome jet brahms how'd you
come up with that
he tells me all sorts of things
okay i just think it's all a little bit
creepy
is this your new friend bronze what are
some of the things you talk about
the other families he's lived with
[Music]
want to take the doll away from him yes
just a whisper first
something is happening to him
[Music]
he knew your boy would find him
[Music]
love you mommy i love you
[Applause]
this poor souls journey has come to an
end
[Music]
from dust we started to dust we return
every corpse tells a story it is our
task to listen
so these are all stories about how
people died
[Applause]
[Music]
some tales even i find too unsettling to
recount
she's dead you gotta get that body out
of your apartment
keep your doors locked tonight and keep
an eye out for crazies oh monsters
that's pretty cool yes it is isn't it
[Applause]
there's no use running your story
is just beginning
[Music]
okay all right let's do this i know it
feels fast
but it's nice isn't it to have a family
unit
come on in and meet the boys they're
really excited to meet you
[Music]
how you feeling about school you can
meet some new friends
i know why the caged bird sings wow
that is super nasty
all right enough settle down
hey it happens to everyone he's made us
all cry at one point or another
you should come over after school
[Music]
what is all this this is a ceremony
to celebrate you
why would you celebrate me because
you're out fourth
just in time for first period
this is all just a little crazy half the
battle of having powers is believing you
do
that's why covens have always been
important
[Music]
if we can do that what else can we do
we need to put a spell on timmy we don't
want to hurt him though right
she's right the number one rule of the
craft
if a person is a danger to herself or
others
they will be bound
i'm starting to get a little worried
sorry i was just hanging out with my
friends
we've gone too far was this just like
some game to you
i feel
be different a lot of weirdos out here
we are the weirdos mister
foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on
hey neighbor you see anything weird
outside your house you tell me
all right
dad mom's being weird
[Music]
mom's always been weird
what are you doing up here yeah don't
let her in my son
likes to play hide and seek can you
bring him down
i didn't say he was here you're a very
stupid boy
can i help you you still at home down
here baby you know your son dylan
i don't have a son he had no idea who i
was talking about
he's gone i know it
i'd like to report a missing kid
are you okay ben where is your sister i
need you to tell me what's going on
[Music]
hey all you shark week fans out there
welcome back
it's our third summer here at little
happy in abandoned fishing village in
the mozambique channel
sharks return here each year their home
like ours
is under attack from climate change
emma what's wrong
a half dozen people went missing about
100 miles up the orange river
turns out it was bull sharks so what do
we do
there is a boy in the field it's big
shark
[Music]
brown where are you there he is
those sharks have been altered engineer
they're not sharks
climate change is making them highly
aggressive towards everything
it's all about survival folks
that was close
when you see someone change in front of
you
[Music]
and you know there's no going back
scares me to death
no one's been here in months it's
beautiful
i love you though i love you too does
anyone need a refill yes
please have you seen this out here
before
it's in the trees it's all over
something in the air
i felt a little light-headed before it
was too good
it's like i was knocked out i can't
remember
mr turner
man
miss turner where's mr turner
is so nice out today
hello what is going on i don't know
something from the water
i can feel it inside
[Music]
i'm just having so much fun how are you
hospital
don't be scared don't be scared
[Music]
me
[Music]